Dave Chappelle.
This is at a
comedy arena in San Francisco.
Comedian Dave Chappelle
brought out
Elon Musk on stage
and Musk was booed for several m
We'll get your response to watch
but I don't want to hear
they are going to make some nois
for the richest man in the world
Eli
It is
way
we're expecting this lawyer.
I couldn't hear Dave there.
Okay. But what? Okay.
He has time to go to a Dave
Chappelle show.
He's, like, running Twitter. Tes
Not there enough, but. Sorry, I
What do you make?
And is it booze?
I'm sure some people were happy
but it sounds like mostly booze
And that was in Silicon Valley.
That's his hometown.
Yeah.
I mean, I think, you know, in a
it's like the power.
I mean, we're talking about Joe
not caring that much about Twitt
I mean, that actually
is the power of Twitter to chang
how Elon Musk is seen very, very
And I think you know, he's been
essentially a lot of right wing
And so when he shows up at in
San Francisco at a comedy show,
tough reception.
Well, not even just right wing p
What he tweeted over the weekend
which is the latest thing
that he's been under fire for,
which, you know,
when you talk to
some of the people around this,
they think this is distracting
when he tweets
the things that we've been talki
about for weeks on the show.
But the thing about falsely
saying his pronouns
were, prosecute Foushee.
And now all these lawmakers
have been criticizing that as we
And Mark Kelly calling him out.
Well, that's what I mean,
Scott Kelly
Andrews, of misinformation
and the dangers of
what Twitter can do
is it can incite people
to towards violence, and it can'
It can also incite people toward
to it, can it,
to do
good things right
it can encourage people to do
good things,
but it can incite people to viol
and it can give up misinformatio
But that is a, you know,
public sentiment.
You know,
that's not just people tweeting.
That's people saying
voting with their mouths going,
Yeah.
I mean,
it can definitely incite people
booing, apparently.
And in this case and I mean,
and I think right.
More broadly, it's
you know,
I think you had people
managing the platform
who were very worried
about the things
that you just talked about,
particularly after January six.
Ban Donald Trump from the platfo
ban that
sort of a spectrum of people on
because I think of their concern
about violence.
And Musk is pulling
it is saying, you guys, you went
trying to pull it back.
There is
I think there's a reasonable arg
going on about free speech.
But Musk is
separately just totally torching
brand for lots of people who lik
I know we have to go,
but let me just say this.
I think we can sit here in Ameri
and because we're we're privileg
when it comes to free speech
and we can criticize Twitter and
oh, I shouldn't do this,
I shouldn't do that.
But if it goes away,
it does have real world conseque
For people who are in countries
without free speech and who use
So glad you said that.
Who use it to get the word out
about the
mistreatment of women
and and LGBTQ community and so o
So it's important to us.
But we're as Americans,
we're like free speech,
you know, what do we do?
Take it off?
Because we have other outlets.
But some people
back to that free speech debate
and so here for it, I
think people misunderstand
how it applies to a company like